je vais bien posée alors tout de suite
jeudi j'ai la phobie du pain envoyé
jeudi qu'elle y faut pas jouer avec ça
si ça ouais jamais ce que c'est une
foule d'amis est sérieux tu lui fais un
comme ça allez comme ça avec son mec
dans la nuit qu'est ce que c'est cheryl
c'est encore ce foutu cauchemar de
palier
j'ai vu du parcours
elle y est l'hiver regarde des films
d'horreur genre la revanche du pain aux
céréales savez les gens quittent rap qui
trompent leur taille leurs racines dans
le lait pour moi ça c'est le truc le
plus horrible non non tu parles si je
peux pas je suis très aride où dès
maintenant s'engager pas là mais je ne
peux pas bouger du tandem les fichiers
même nom pouvait pas avaler allez-y je
sais pas vous dire que je peux bien pour
ça mais c'est pas grave on est prêt pour
vous irez sur moi a très envie à laisser
toucher pas pour nous mais pour voir ce
que ça vous fait allez je vais pas du
tout aimé moi regardez moi ça lâche
cette arme pauvre être en conséquence
[Applaudissements]
oui
mais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
je vous en au max tu as perdu sait tout
faire
qu'est ce que tu as dit non j'ai dit au
mieux du pain mouillé une poule mouillée
[Musique]